hey what's up my name is samuel leeds i
am a property investor and in this video
i want to talk to you about passive
income what is passive income and how
can you get it in your life
maybe you're skeptical about passive
income maybe you've never heard of it
before
well i've been in property investment
now for over 10 years i've done a lot of
other businesses as well
and let me tell you something the
biggest myth about passive income
is that passive income is a myth
i'll say that again the biggest myth
about passive income
is that passive income is a myth because
people say that it doesn't exist
in fact the whole throughout my
childhood all through school
it was as though passive income doesn't
exist
because they don't teach you about
passive income they only teach you about
active income
and they don't even call it active
income they just call it income
so all through school in fact most
people all through life
all they know about is active income and
i'll give you some examples of active
income that's when you
go and get a job and you're getting paid
to go to work or even if you're in
business you're getting paid to make a
sale
you get you're trading your time for
money
waiting to retire when you're 67 and
saving money in the meantime that's most
people that's active income
what's passive income passive income and
i'm going to give you four ways that you
can do this
in a moment but passive income is when
you do something once
you set something up once you buy
something once
and then you get paid on and on and on
and you're getting paid while you sleep
that's passive income so what are some
examples of passive income
number one my favorite example is real
estate or property
if anyone's skeptical about passive
income just ask them the question
how many times do you need to keep
buying a property
until the property stops paying you rent
and of course it's a dumb question
because you don't ever buy the property
again you buy it once
and then you get a management company to
put a tenant in there and if the tenant
moves out the management company finds
another tenant
and you the owner just get paid
so i get paid every single month i spend
less than five
minutes a month managing my property
portfolio
and my management companies manage all
the tenants deal with everything
they take all the money minus their
management costs and then
i get the profit every single month that
happens that's going to continue
happening
happening not just all my life but my
kids life
my grandkids life they're gonna keep
getting rent off my properties
you cannot say that is not passive
income
the only way that property is not
passive is if you've set it up whereby
it's not systemized
very easy to systemize so that's number
one
number two is business people say
passive income doesn't exist
why is it then that every single
business by its very definition
is set up to create passive income you
might say what are you talking about
samuel
well a business is not a business unless
you have
staff you have customers and you have
processes
so the processes and the idea of
business is so that it functions
without you and if you've got a business
that's functioning without you
what does that give you that gives you
passive income
and most businesses that are set up
properly
are set up to create ultimately passive
income so that's number two
traditional business number three is
online businesses
now the difference between an online
business and a traditional business
is for an online business you don't even
need staff
i've seen individuals making millions of
pounds
with an online business with
subscription
and they don't even have hardly any or
any staff at all
so online businesses like subscriptions
this is a great way
to get passive income lastly number four
and you can't
argue with this and this that is
royalties
i've written several books how many
times do you have to write a book
once how many times have i got paid for
writing my books
tens and tens and tens of thousands of
times
every time amazon sell one of my books
they send me a commission check at the
end of the month
with all the books that sold i don't do
anything for that income
that is passive income so passive income
is absolutely
real the biggest myth around passive
income is what is that it doesn't exist
the best way in my opinion to create
passive income is through property and
real estate
i hope you enjoyed this video if you did
smash the like button
drop a comment below and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel because i'm
going to be doing more videos teaching
how to create passive income through
property so subscribe
turn on the notification bell and i'll
see you next time